I confess I don't have a very high view
of Christian movies part of that is
because I'm a little nitpicky about
movies in general I'm the guy who sits
there watching the latest Hollywood
Blockbuster thinking to myself well
given the personality disorder this
character exhibited earlier in the film
that's not how he would react in this
situation what he would have done when
confronted with this moral dilemma is
this other thing so for lots of movies I
watch I'm sitting there thinking how did
you spend all this time and money making
this but you didn't fix these obvious
plot holes with Christian movies in
particular I have two additional
problems one it's always in my mind that
if you're making a film to glorify the
almighty it should be absolutely epic it
should be the best film playing in the
theater I understand that production
companies don't always have the budgets
to spend chunks of money on Christian
films although sometimes they do like
the original Ben Hur or The Passion of
the Christ so it's hard to compete with
Hollywood movies that have 200 million
dollar budgets but you can make up for
that by being creative
The Blair Witch Project had a budget of
like sixty thousand dollars it grossed
almost 250 million dollars at the box
office which means you can make a film
that people want to see even on a lower
budget so if you're making it for God
make it awesome making a Christian movie
should be like building a cathedral the
only acceptable outcome is excellence
two Christian movies tend to water down
and oversimplify reality and there's a
reason for that if you're making a
Christian movie part of your target
audience is little old Christian ladies
who are going to go watch it after their
Pastor recommends it at church
you don't want to traumatize these
little old Christian ladies so you have
to be careful about what you put in your
movie
but a lot of Christian movies are about
people who have serious issues massive
moral problems but then they turn to
Jesus at some point and things have to
get watered down to make the story safe
for a Christian audience let's say
you're making a movie about a homeless
drug addict who prostitutes herself to
pay for meth but eventually becomes a
Christian
how do you tell that story
obviously you're not going to show
certain things that would be part of
that person's life but how do you
accurately show anything that would be
part of that person's life
even if you show a conversation this
homeless drug addicted prostitute has
with another character how realistic can
you make that conversation
you have to tone down the language and
the topic matter you have to make the
conversation Christian movie friendly
and in doing so you make the
conversation inauthentic unrealistic in
other words I would be watching that
movie thinking
that is not how these characters would
talk this is like a nice Christian's
idea of how this conversation would go
but not how the conversation would
actually go
now I don't know what you do about this
problem do you make the scenes and the
dialogue so realistic that your
Christian movie ends up being R-rated
and a bunch of your target audience
won't watch it
you don't want to do that so we might
just be stuck with watering down reality
to make it safe for Christian movies
that may be the most effective way to do
things
but I'm usually not terribly interested
in watching it so I wasn't going to go
watch Jesus Revolution because I'm in
the habit of not watching most Christian
films
then my friend John McRae what do you
meme posted a video about it John has
terrible taste in movies music and
friends so his endorsement of a film
would normally be a good reason not to
watch it
but a bunch of people in the comments
said they liked it so my wife and I
headed to the theater
for the first 20 or 30 minutes I was not
impressed it was exactly what I expected
I looked at my watch multiple times
wondering how long I was going to have
to sit there but then the movie started
to grow on me I used to watch cheers
back in the day so I like Frasier Crane
he plays a pastor in Jesus Revolution a
pastor who decides against the wishes of
certain members of his congregation to
invite hippies into his church
all of the acting was good some of the
dialogue was standard kind of cheesy
Christian movie dialogue but this kind
of cheesy Christian movie dialogue was
eventually overshadowed by some really
good dialogue and more importantly by
some very significant very meaningful
very timely messages and keep in mind
Jesus Revolution is a true story about a
Christian Revival in California
two big takeaways from Jesus revolution
first the main point of the film is that
Christians shouldn't be Pharisees
hippies made Christians really
uncomfortable hippies were these young
people walking around Barefoot living in
tents not taking showers getting high
and having sex in the park
do you want these weirdos in your church
of course not a bunch of smelly hippies
walking into your church would make your
congregation extremely uncomfortable
but when did being comfortable become
the supreme goal of Christianity Jesus
didn't make people comfortable he made
people really really uncomfortable he
made people so uncomfortable that they
wanted him dead
and one of the things he did that made
people really really uncomfortable was
that he would hang out with the outcasts
of society people that the Pharisees the
religious Elite of that time wouldn't
touch with a stick
Jesus would hang out with tax collectors
and prostitutes and tax collectors in
first century Israel were not like IRS
agents these were Jewish Tax Collectors
who collected money from their fellow
Jews for their Roman oppressors Tax
Collectors were viewed as Traders
selling out their own people for profit
but Jesus would eat with them and have
discussions with them one of the tax
collectors even became an apostle the
Apostle Matthew
Jesus associated with outcasts
and when people would ask him why are
you hanging out with these sinners
he would reply
it's not the healthy who need a doctor I
didn't come for the righteous
came for Sinners came for the Lost
that idea should be built into
Christianity and yet every generation
has its share of Pharisees the Pharisees
weren't just a first century Jewish
group The Pharisee mindset is always
with us telling us stay away from those
people those people are too awful
in fact as I was watching Jesus
Revolution checking my watch and we got
to the part where Frazier started
bringing hippies into his church and
some of his congregation left I began
wondering
am I being a film Pharisee
do I think I'm too good for this movie
because it's not Mad Max Fury Road am I
sitting here in judgment instead of just
watching a film and seeing where it goes
indeed I was I was being a film Pharisee
but I kept watching and they did an
excellent job making a point about
Christians doing the difficult work of
opening their arms to society's outcasts
like Jesus did
second Jesus Revolution made a good
point about God using people who are far
from perfect the original disciples of
Jesus were a band of Misfits then they
were joined by the Apostle Paul who
started off as a Pharisee and a
Christian killer and somehow this band
of Misfits turned the world upside down
even after the most powerful Empire the
world had ever seen targeted them for
Destruction
and when you watch Jesus Revolution you
see a bunch of deeply flawed people
leading a Christian Revival one of those
people Lonnie Frisby is someone that a
lot of Christians would like to erase
from the history of the California
Revival Lonnie frisbee in the movie and
in real life
was the hippie Who convinced Pastor
Chuck Smith I.E Frazier crane to invite
hippies into his church Lonnie said
these young people are looking for all
the right things in all the wrong places
they're like sheep without a shepherd
and somehow Christians want nothing to
do with them
Lonnie frisbee had some awesome
qualities and some serious problems he
loved Jesus he loved people he also had
serious psychological and moral problems
it would have been very easy to ignore
or minimize his role in the Jesus
revolution in California instead the
film highlights his role in the Revival
showing that God continues using Misfits
to reach the loss hats off to the
writers and producers for not giving in
to the Relentless urge to make
Christians seem better than we are
so should you go see Jesus Revolution
while it's still in theaters you can of
course always see it some other way
later but there's one more consideration
here
Hollywood production companies are
always paying close attention to who
shows up to the movie theaters
if you'd like to see more Christian
films you can actually send a message by
what you watch now you don't want to go
see bad Christian movies just because
they're Christian movies that sends the
wrong message that sends the message
that Christians will watch garbage as
long as it's got something to do with
Jesus so you don't want to go see bad
Christian movies
but if a Christian film is worth
watching Christians should go watch it
and Jesus Revolution is worth watching
side note for those of you with normally
functioning human emotions my wife was
crying for like half the movie so Jesus
Revolution is apparently quite moving
for normal people
[Music]
thank you